they're testing one two three four mic
check testing welcome back to the
machine learning street talk youtube
channel
today is a really special episode we've
got an absolute
legend alex stanley i introduce him
properly on the show so we won't get too
bogged down in that but
today we're talking all about kernels do
you remember kernels
those things that people used to use
before deep learning
most people have forgotten all about
them even i have and i
did a phd at royal holloway and royal
holloway was
on the forefront of colonels i think we
had vladimir vapnik was one of our
distinguished professors there i must
admit
just to prepare for this episode i had a
little look at chapter six of bishop
and it made me realize either forgotten
most stuff about colonels or perhaps i
didn't even understand half of it in the
first place but
today was a really cool episode because
alex took us through the whole thing we
we talk about
the kernel trick how it's used in things
like kernel ridge regression and support
vector machines
we go down the rabbit hole on the
mercer's theorem and the
representer theorem and reproducing
colonel hilbert spaces
and how kernels in general
compare to modern deep learning
approaches and so on so
it was an amazing episode and it was a
huge honor to have alex on the show so
i hope you enjoy it and we will see you
back
next week by the way if you haven't
liked
and commented and indeed subscribed to
the channel
it's disappointing see you next week
i i find this very exciting especially
this final connection that
kind of the the data points are the
model
and our recognition now that we've gone
away from this we've gone to neural
networks which
we fed through data and we're like ha we
have this parametric thing right here we
don't we can throw away the data points
to
to the transformers where we know
we can't just increase the parameters we
also need to increase
the data which to me is the same thing
even though
it ends up being you can maybe evaluate
quicker because you can just forward
past but it's
i just i feel like there's a kind of a
reconnection in
in that space happening definitely and
and i'm excited to see what happens in
the future so yeah alex
this was great thank you very much oh
jesus the glass has never come off
no this is the branding man i was really
worried that yannick had no eyeballs or
something but
there is a video of him online without
the glasses
because otherwise i'm just wondering how
does he even read anything
yeah uh i wear my sunglasses at night et
[Music]
cetera
there's a casey neistat he does these
videos where he like wakes up in the
morning
and he has his blanket over his head and
then he's like alarm sounds and he goes
and he already has the sunglasses on
now what i've actually done is i've got
a second
piece to camera yeah you see this is for
the intro
do you like that yeah nice yeah i don't
about
we do things properly here on street
talk
only
[Laughter]
today we have an incredibly special
guest
he's so incredibly special i forgot to
introduce yannick lightspeed culture
beforehand
and it's best i do that beforehand
because i've got a bit of a preamble to
go through here but
alex stenleigh he loves solving data
puzzles
and working on statistical analysis and
machine learning and time series and
he's got a passion
for causal inference and also for
bayesian modelling and graphs
so uh super cool guy he's got an
interesting background so he started out
in the army
and then he went on to get a first class
degree in international uh relations and
political science from the university of
queensland
where he implemented data-driven causal
models of genocide
using bayesian networks he's the
co-organizer of the queensland ai
society with
over 3000 members and lots of regular
events
he was a senior research data analyst at
university of queensland for a year
specializing in bioinformatics
he was doing research in the university
sector for a while and then he pivoted
into the startup scene
so he was the head of analytics at
canaria working on things like signal
processing and machine learning models
and bi and data
architecture and now he's pivoted
towards china
he just decided randomly to go to china
just as australia went into the lockdown
he's learning chinese like a man
possessed he's already done a stint
accenture and when he's not solving data
puzzles he's climbing mountains and and
that's not a euphemism for adaptive
gradient methods by the way
he reached out to us when janik did a
really cool video on applying kernels to
transformers and alex picked yannick up
on loads of bits and pieces and
basically we just decided it would be a
cool show for us to do and anyway alex
welcome to the show
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here yeah you can be honest i just
screwed up all the kernel talk
that's how this happened the kernels
the kernel thing is though like everyone
screws them up and they're
super simple and that's why i was like
oh come on like
we we can get this right it's not
anyone's fault it's just
i think they're kind of taught badly or
explained badly on the internet so
i'm going to add my own bad explanation
today and and see how terribly i can
explain it
i think this especially now in the i
i feel we were at a transition where
academia
is still in this so there's this path of
machine learning that you go through
starting with whatever regression and
whatnot and through one way or the other
you go to you get to to kernels usually
you want to you have your linear
classifier and your support vector
machine and
and so on and it seems like that's
that's
this chapter and it used to be the thing
to do
in classification it used to be we have
these svms and they perform super well
and that might still be in you know
industry but in academia then it's like
chapter close
now we go to neural networks and the
hype today is
neural net at least from my perspective
in academia is like neural networks and
so kernels becomes this thing that
most of us have seen at some point
uh but you know we forget a hundred
percent like i
i started learning straight into deep
learning i was very lucky
and oh i had an intellectual curiosity
about like how this developed and
between like kernel methods and deep
learning
there was a period where random forests
were just like everything
oh yeah even things like the kinect is
powered by a random forest because that
was the most powerful
model that you know was practical at the
time but
at the same time i was hanging out with
a lot of mathematicians and
they loved their kernels they absolutely
love them and i'm
i knew nothing about maths at the time i
basically self-taught through asking
them
a lot of stupid questions and through
their patience
i remember there was one day i was just
sitting there i'm like oh i get this
we're actually running through bishop
anyone out there that's
interested in machine learning bishop's
still like a really good reference for
getting a good overall picture of the
theory that underpins us all and so
we're in this lecture post docs and
lecturers professors i'm just asking
these questions
and a lot of my friends from the math
school they're like he's all right but
his math isn't very good and this day
they're like
holy hell he's he's understanding this
the boy is learning
so yeah so this is extremely appreciated
because i yeah i think it's just this
thing that
the community has forgotten it pops out
here and there
every now and then in transformers here
and
people are trying to apply it so what do
you think is the biggest
like the the flaw that people do when
teaching kernels
where do you think it comes from or what
could be done better
okay so to jump in a way i think the
biggest problem
is that we don't think in terms of
statistical learning theory anymore
we think in terms of engineering like we
know we need a loss function we need
some data source
we need some differentiable function and
away we go the rest is engineering
whereas the kernel methods come from a
time where
we didn't really have cloud compute our
computers were still pretty slow and
very memory limited
doing any kind of learning whatsoever
was a challenge and so you didn't mess
around with something that you weren't
relatively sure would work
and so people spend a lot of time
thinking these problems through and
ensuring they were properly
defined and that it would converge to
something useful
and of course they weren't just doing
throwing sgd at everything they were
using closed form uh sorry not closed
form arm
convex optimizers quadratic optimizes
linear programming and that that was the
mindset at the time
and i guess at the same time like there
was this earlier wave of neural networks
that had just gone out of fashion and it
was deemed that
that's not the approach no we need to
move back to a more theoretically
grounded
approach and so the mathematicians came
out and there were gains there were huge
gains and some really cool theorems that
come out of that time like the no free
lunch theorem etc
weirdly neural networks are more
computationally tractable than something
svms don't have a closed form solution
they're those yeah
lagrange multipliers and yeah you have
to use a
quadratic programming tool in matlab
probably and
it's very problematic as well so
sometimes you have to adjust the bounds
and the parameters to make it work and
if you can get it to work on on over
5000 examples you're doing well
and there were there were heuristics
weren't there to break it yeah and then
take the union over the solutions but
carriage regression was different
because you could solve a linear system
and you didn't need to
compute the inverse directly yeah and
i guess solution isn't it yeah with
ridge regression there is a closed form
solution and svms are different but
that's mainly because the optimization
problem is different
if you were to do like svm regression
it's basically the same thing
and it's really down to it's really down
to the the objective that we're
optimizing i believe like i'm no expert
on svms themselves but i'm pretty sure
it's hinge loss that
really throws up the problems rather
than doing the kernel regression itself
because you know ridge regression ridge
regression in the dual format
is regression spoiler warning we'll uh
we'll work through that later
how we actually get there but if anyone
out there is intimidated by the maths of
this sort of stuff
i i think let's put a bit of a warning
here
we initially discussed how to strip the
maths out of this as much as we could
how to just talk about the intuition
and how to how to think about this
particular problem
the the problem is the more i thought
about this the more i dug into
the field and okay how do i explain this
properly and and leave no loose hands
the more i realize there's some level of
mathematical abstraction that's
necessary but uh that being said we're
not
gonna do anything rigorous we're gonna
hand wave a lot we're gonna say oh it's
a lot like this thing here
and this is gonna make the maths people
rage so it to whom i say
go read a book you already you should
already know this stuff just
already straightforward stop bothering
the rest of us
and so yeah the as we build up to this
stuff we're gonna
the spoiler warning is we're gonna be
doing linear regression in the end it's
gonna look exactly like linear
regression
you can solve it like you would
literally a linear model in pi torch
the only difference is we're going to be
doing it with this crazy mathematical
space in the background that allows us
to do non-linear stuff
you know in something that comes out to
solving for a bunch of coefficients
but how to get there is a challenge and
disambiguating like
what is a kernel why does it have all
these crazy infinite dimensions how does
all that stuff work that's a challenge
why don't we start with what is a kernel
okay
yeah i'll outline briefly where we're
going to go just for the sake of
everyone so they've got a clear picture
we're going to start with this question
of what is a kernel
then from there we're going to move on
to probably the densest
part mathematically which is what's a
reproducing kernel hilbert space
and that's a mouthful there's a lot more
mouthfuls in there but that'll give us
everything that we need
to understand the final part the the
magic of kernel methods which is the
representer theorem
and once we have the represented theorem
in hand everything kind of snaps into
focus
with what is a kernel let's start by
talking about what it's not
because a kernel in kernel methods is
not necessarily
a mathematical kernel so when people are
talking about kernel
like this is one of the first horrible
things about kernel methods the word
kernel is
horribly confused with a lot of concepts
i remember when i was first
looking into this stuff i'm like oh does
this have anything to do with the kernel
of an os or your jupiter kernel
no not as far as i can tell cnn as well
you know convolution one that's actually
closer to the sort of kernel that we're
going to be talking about but in between
that a matrix kernel
what's a matrix kernel a matrix kernel
is like a zero function
for a matrix space and actually the
definition of what is just a kernel
if you say ask a mathematician what's
the kernel they're going to say oh it's
the
generalization of the zero function and
the matrix kernel it acts like this zero
it's also known as the null space or the
kernel of the matrix
but in kernel methods there's also the
kernel matrix and the kernel matrix is
not the matrix kernel
it is not the kernel of the matrix so
you'll see
you'll see matrix kernel come up no
that's nothing to do with kernel methods
that's like straight up
generalization of non-negative or
strictly positive numbers
to give a concrete example of what that
means it's like a matrix
where all the eigenvalues are positive
or at least non-zero
right so it's otherwise how can you say
a matrix is greater than equal uh
greater than or equal to zero
so okay we have to define something and
that's called our our positive
semi-definite
uh matrix you were saying the properties
of kernels are
they need to be positive semi-definite
right no no not not
where where the kernels we're going to
be talking about are positive
semi-definite kernels
um apologies is is it not um because i
think there is a mercer theorem thing
right which said yeah yeah yeah
so there has to be symmetric has to be
positive semi-definite and that's when
you have
any vector and you have a sleeping
version and a
and a standing version you multiply them
all together and all the values have to
be greater than zero
sleeping and standing i love it yeah
basically that's what we're talking
about here
it's this idea that positive numbers or
positive
things don't just have to be numbers
that we can define other things to be
positive
so okay we've got this positive object
this positive function
some examples are things that work like
this are your cnn
filters your discrete signal uh signal
processing filters your window functions
for like uh rolling means and stuff in
in pandas implicit surfaces defined by
distance in point set
in point cloud calculations density
estimators and integrators right like
there's a huge these positive definite
functions these positive definite
kernels
these are all called kernels oh um
covariance matrices and covariance
functions from statistics right these
show up everywhere
but we're going to be talking about a
very specific form of them for the sake
of when you
when you talk about cnn cnn filters
they're not
like the matrix as such is not
necessarily positive seminars no no but
the function is positive semi-definite
in an abstract sense okay
yeah and that's the trick here the the
kernels can be far more general
than just the kernels used in kernel
methods but thankfully we only need to
worry about a very simple class of them
and uh when we're talking about kernel
functions
basically think about distance functions
think about functions that are symmetric
right order arguments doesn't matter
they're generally they're generally
positive definite strictly positive
definite but
for statistics and for machine learning
we can generalize them to positive
semi-definite
which means x sorry your function equals
zero only when x equals y
and if you just think about them like a
similarity measure or a distance
function
you're done right that's all the
intuition you need to move forward here
i think as well as the the symmetry and
the positive
semi-definite thing to be there are some
rules to be a valid kernel
yes and i think the the the most
important rule is that there is a latent
space
and in that latent space it has to
represent an inner product and that's
actually not true for many high-level
transformations so for example there's
the polynomial kernel
well for it for a reproducing kernel
that needs to be the case
but for a general kernel kernels are
more general than that
and to get to the reproducing kernel we
need to start defining what the function
space and stuff like that is
so and it's this is structuring it like
this
it sounds dumb it really does being so
pedantic over the meaning of words
but it really like when you go back and
you start reading things reading
text start to pull this theory apart for
yourself it
makes it helps a lot to keep these ideas
separate in your head
just for the sake of for your own for
the sake of your own sanity
so that when you see people referring to
kernels in a way that doesn't quite make
sense you can say okay well what are
they actually talking about here
because there are many ways to split
this particular idea and implement this
particular idea
right oh we mentioned earlier the kernel
matrix that's not the matrix kernel
when we're talking about the kernel
matrix here we're just going to be
talking about pairwise distances
of all data points in a data set right
that's our definitions done we have our
kernel function we know what they're not
we have our kernel matrix we have
basically every tool we need to start
moving forward
through the abstract stuff with some
language that's going to help us here
so the kernel matrix is just a kernel
matrix
the entry i j is simply the kernel
function applied to date to point i
and date to point j yes but what is our
kernel function well that depends
a good example of a kernel matrix here
would be like a gram matrix where we
just take the inner product of
everything
that's a valid kernel matrix that if
you're struggling to to move forward in
this i'm assuming all your listeners
know
about it know how to do basic deep
learning stuff and so they'll they'll
know what an inner product is and they
can imagine a matrix full of inner
products
if you're ever stuck just think in your
head we're talking about in a matrix
full inner products
but on the annex point though so inner
product matrix is where let's say
you have a whole bunch of examples and
and you take the dot product between all
of them and you
end up with an m by n matrix but you
haven't done any transformation but
yannick was saying what you could do
is you could have a feature
transformation first
on all of the pairs of examples and then
that could be represented in
in this kernel matrix but what the
kernel matrix gives you
is you don't have to explicitly compute
that feature transformation
so you do it you do this kernel function
and
the kernel functions seem to be there's
not many you can do they seem to be
either i think sigmoids or polynomials
and you have like homogeneous ones which
are
only a function of the distance between
the examples and you have
ones which are some kind of
transformation but but my point is that
the actual kernel functions themselves
are typically quite simple yeah and this
is the trick right
the whole reason this field works is
because we find ways of not having to
calculate those feature maps
and uh to do those big inner products we
can just do point wise
saw like pairwise evaluation on all the
elements of two vectors
throw that into a matrix and we're done
and that's like
the beauty here but one other weird
thing because
we've talked about all the things that
make a valid kernel but with the radial
basis function for example i think it's
a kind of taylor series expansion so
it's actually
the inner product is is in is yes but
the only reason why that works is
because it decays very quickly
so if it didn't if it didn't converge to
zero
on that series expansion then it would
be a crappy curve because if you add it
all up
it would it just wouldn't be useful i
think there's one it might be the matern
kernel or something like that which does
have it it's vaguely tailor seriously it
doesn't drop off quite so fast
but it is very big and it seems to work
fairly well
for certain classes of problems online
nowhere differentiable functions
but like uh the the actual applications
of this like
realistically you use rbf for everything
it's the theory that underpins these
things that are interesting and the way
they keep showing up in different
domains
but does that indicate though that even
though it's technically an infinite
dimensional
space because it decays so quickly it's
only really
the first few that are important imagine
you're doing a polynomial kernel
on like fifth order polynomials or
something like that and you've got a
hundred input variables
that's a very big calculation if you can
reduce that to like an element-wise
operation an element-wise operation and
an aggregation then you're already doing
pretty well
and that's really where the magic comes
from the fact that you can
get away with these ridiculous these
ridiculous reductions on that full
feature map
expansion so i just
i think we're jumping like 10-15 minutes
ahead
but it's a good it's a good point you
just go okay what does it
so now we have kernel functions and the
kernel matrix
and let's say we want to explicitly
build that kernel matrix
in and and let's just make an example
let's take a
polynomial degree 3 whatever
and that's going to be our kernel
function how so now i have my polynomial
right and i have my data points what do
i do
with that there's kind of two ways you
could go about this you can calculate
the full
polynomial expansion right which makes
your matrix like
much bigger then you calculate the inner
product or you get your kernel function
and you whack in your original vectors
and calculate just on that original
vector which is much smaller
and then put that element into the the
kernel matrix so end up with it
yeah what i would do is i take my data
point which
has maybe let's say
i don't know how many does the data
point need to have as many features as i
have
polynomial entries no this is not
completely independent all right so i
have my
data point and i just enter every single
dimension of my data point
through this and expand it into the
polynomial so i do this many x squared
this many x cubed so i end up with like
number of features
times number of coefficients you'd end
up for one data point you'd end up
number of features times number of
dimensions in your polynomial
entries numbers right if you're
calculating it
the the way you're using feature and
then i basically
exactly i'll unravel all of this and
then
i take the inner product of that with
another data point to which i do the
same thing and that'll give me
one entry in this matrix at i j
if i take yes data points up okay so
that's or
or you just use the kernel function and
you get the same answer but much quicker
yeah exactly you never do the full
expansion because
one of the things is you may not be able
to do that calculation it's easy with
polynomials polynomials are great
rbf you're not going to be able to do
that full expansion
and even though it decays you still
technically need it for for this stop
for the results to hold and so yeah it's
so the kernel
function for the polynomial how would
that look like if i did this again i
have data points i and j i want the
this entry with the polynomial i don't
remember that
i don't remember that because it's a
different function that's important
right yeah
it's some other function you can get to
it by
somehow modifying this polynomial and
you can say here just put the two data
points
through this and then you'll get the
same number
yes so a quick question why is this not
overfitting
suicide okay there are
a couple of good reasons for that oh man
we're going through this talk backwards
the part of the reason it's not
overfitting city is because
we're suddenly not regressing on the
number of
variables we're regressing on the number
of data points right so
we end up with this great big square
matrix which we're going to end up doing
linear regression on
and that's how we end up solving this
problem but sorry just to challenge that
though
are we not effectively transforming it
into a latent space which is
ridiculously highly dimensional yes
typically we seem to be using like
linear methods in that latent space
all of these dimensions they are very
much dependent on each other
and and furthermore we're only
evaluating at the number of uh data
points that we have
actually let's pivot into the theory
let's talk about hilbert spaces for a
bit
so for anyone out there that doesn't
know what a hillbit space is
these are just they're just basically
vector spaces like rn that you're really
comfortable with
we don't need to worry too much about
the the details of how they work
the real trick is rn's basis vectors are
these like orthogonal unit vectors that
live
at the heart of the space right at the
origin and we take linear combinations
of these to build other vectors
with hilbert spaces we can use more
general objects as our bases for example
sine functions or the components of a
polynomial
and that's the real there's only kind of
two conditions that need to hold here
the vector space needs to be linear
additivity and community commutativity
etc
and needs to have a scalar in a product
as long as these two things hold these
two kind of very general notions
we can define the bases to be all kinds
of crazy objects
and these spaces are big right like they
can be made to be much bigger than
rn even if we set n to infinity just
imagine the space of all polynomials
with uh with real valued coefficients
that's already like a bigger space
than we'd expect from like integer value
coefficients which
like why some why is it isomorphic yeah
it'd probably be isomorphic to
rn don't quote me on that but but the
real trick to these spaces
is we can start to use our nice
geometric
intuitions everyone knows how well maybe
not everyone knows how vectors transform
but
most people that would be watching this
show would be fairly comfortable with
how a vector transforms
and we can use all those intuitions
except now we're reasoning with like
functions or your sinusoidal bases or
fourier bases or something like that
if we just understand a hilbert space is
this very general playground to start
setting up problems
then that's the first step from there we
can get a reproducing kernel hill but
space by adding a reproducing kernel all
right cool what's a reproducing kernel
one of the one of the things i found
when i was going
was doing the prep for this i found a
definition of reproducing colonel
hilbert's space that basically said oh
it's a kernel hilbert space of functions
that has a reproducing kernel and i
thought oh this is the most
useless definition i've ever found but
have you ever heard how they define a
tensor
a tensor is defined as an object that
transforms like a tensor
wow oh my god that that's improvement
yeah at least we know we're dealing with
functions we've got one additional bit
of information
and so there's a better definition for
how we get these paces and this is
all building up to how this stuff maps
down when we're talking about the
reproducing kernel hilbert space we can
also think of it as a space of functions
where the point evaluation functional
we'll get to that
is linear and continuous all right a
functional is just a function
that takes in a function and and returns
another function so you can think of
the derivative operator as a functional
but what's the evaluation functional
all right so we've got a space of
functions and ideally we'd like to know
how these functions
if we pass an argument into these
functions how they work
but our functions aren't defined on a
space yet basically what the evaluation
function
evaluation function lets us do is
transform f or g
or h to f of x or g of x or h of x
like it gives us an argument if we think
about our polynomial space let's just
take a two dimensional space where this
axis here is our um
x vector and this is our x squared
except we don't have x
yet because we haven't hit it we haven't
defined it on a space
the 0.11 would be something square or
the function of something is equal to
something squared
plus something right so then we hit it
with the evaluation functional at x and
we get f of x is equal to x squared plus
x
evaluation functional of y is is
f of y is equal to y squared etcetera
throw in 2 and we get 6 because we can
actually reduce that
to a single variable at that point or a
single number
so if you can get if you can grasp that
what this thing is is it's a function
that kind of allows us to go through
this space of functions
and figure out what it'll evaluate to at
a single point
then what the meaning of it being linear
and continuous kind of makes it just
jumps out at you it means as we evaluate
like
let's fix x to be two as we sweep it
through the space
it's gonna it's gonna give us smooth
answers and
the the consequence of this is that if
we
are if we are doing if we are converging
in the function space as we're searching
through it for our optimal classifying
function or something like that
it means that what the outputs will be
converging themselves
now the opposite isn't true but it
basically means as we search through
this space we're going to be getting
better and better answers
and it just guarantees a certain
niceness for looking for functions
even though the functions themselves may
be horrible the
evaluation functional itself is nice and
smooth
so we can just to be like the the space
of functions that we're
we're talking about that's not the
hilbert space right now we're separating
we're in a hilbert space yeah but space
where the basis is defined by functions
okay and where we're now trying to see
if there's a reproducing kernel
and like sport spoiler most reproducing
most hilbert spaces
do have do have a reproducing kernel you
can construct ones that don't
but most of them work like this this is
a a relatively
fundamental thing it's going to sound
like yeah of course it's got to be like
that
how could it be any other way but it it
actually doesn't like equivalence
classes of functions for example
they they don't have a reproducing
kernel
is there an equivalence to deep learning
here in the
sense because you know one of the things
about deep learning is that it's this
continuous geometric
uh morphing from from one manifold to
another manifold and this is a similar
idea but instead of
being in a geometric space if you have
basis functions
in this hillbid space you can
continuously go from one function to
another
yeah one way of thinking about a neural
network that
should be fairly helpful is if you just
set all the bases to be all the
parameters of a neural network
and as rd is a hilbert space but you
need to
then account for like the layering
effect so some of the bases would
include the outputs of
other areas of the space so they
wouldn't be independent
but yeah the big reason that the there's
a
similarity here is it turns out that if
you want to go looking for functions
like weird non-linear functions not
having big jumps or discontinuities in
your space is
very handy you know you don't want
surprises in there
so i'm imagining like just to clarify
this because i'm imagining a picture
here where
on one hand i have my let's say i have
rd like r to the three with just the
numbers in it and
a function on that space would simply
map every single point
to an output yeah it's like okay how how
warm is it in every
piece of my room okay so every single
point has a number cool
and then i'm imagining this other space
the space of functions that somehow
there's just like this cloud of
functions and i can pick
one of those functions and i can apply
to this
to my room and that function will try to
tell me how warm it is now it might not
be correct right
every possible function here but i'm
trying to find the best that's what i'm
doing with machine learning i'm trying
to find in this cloud of functions the
best function
to apply over here to tell me what the
actual temperature
in the room is closest to what it really
is yes
the evaluation function is the thing
that picks a function
and applies it right here and we want
that this evaluation functional
is continuous and linear yes
yes okay perfect so basically we but the
evaluation function is just the thing
that picks and
puts so we can also imagine that the
space over here
somehow he's such that functions that
are next to each other
only vary like a little bit exactly
exactly and that's why we're
constructing it this way
um and why did i go on about the
evaluation functional like couldn't we
just say oh
the functions do this but turns out if
you use the evaluation functional you
can construct a thing called a
reproducing kernel
and to get there we're going to take the
inner product of two very special
functions
because it turns out let's fix the
reproducing kernel let's say it's it
evaluates at the point x it turns out
that all these reproducing kernel
hilbert spaces
will have a special function somewhere
in their space
like within the space that if you take
any other function in the space
and take the inner product of those two
functions and this special function will
be defined for x
you take the inner product and it's the
same as hitting hitting
the the any function you choose with the
evaluation function
so you can turn the evaluation
functional into an inner product
and this is important because you can
get two of those special functions
and take the inner product of those two
functions and end up
with a special function that
behaves as if it behaves as if it is
the inner product of arbitrary functions
within the space
if we asserted that the latent space
needs to be an inner product is that
basically what you just said
because it is an inner product because
it's a hilbert space it's
endowed with a scalar in a product so it
has to be an inner product
yeah we we use the fact that it's an
inner product to
find a function that um behaves
like uh behaves like evaluating a
function
another function in the space we have
our evaluation function and let's call
our new function what a right and
we have our evaluation functional at x
and our a at x
then you pick any f in the space and
that gives you the same answer
as e of f which gives you essentially
like
f of x right now you take two of these
functions
these special functions defined it x
and say y and put them together and it's
the same as taking the inner product
of the functions in that space evaluated
at that point at points x and y and you
can construct them in such a way
using again using positive
semi-definiteness
and this new special function is the
same as taking the inner products
in the space isn't that the same as what
we were saying in general then so there
is an evaluation function which is our
kernel function and then
in this phase we design it so that it's
the same
as the inner product of this function in
the hilbit space
kind yeah except the evaluation
functions for a point and now we've got
one that can do it with the inner
product between
two between two functions and often
there are efficiencies in setting it up
in a certain way
so if what like going back
to at the beginning you said if you take
to
the inner product of two functions in
this function space
so is there any special notion to this
or is that just the mathematician
sitting there and saying well it's a
hilbert space so it has an inner product
or how can we imagine how can we imagine
the inner product between
two functions in that space two
functions in that space the same
imagine we're going to do because
because we set up
the function space it has basis vectors
right so
no they're not basis vectors they're
basically basis functions
yeah it has some kind of it has some
kind of bases yeah and every function in
that space can be expressed in terms of
these
bases so if it's it's not the space of
any arbitrary function but it could be
the space of any
functions can like the space of
polynomials because we can represent
them with nice
bases bases polynomials or base
monomials
yeah and or it can be the space
i well let's leave the gaussians out for
now because that's going to be
what gets us to this infinite dimensions
right because it has
infinite but and then the inner product
is simply
i decompose the two polynomials each
into their bases into their coefficients
and then i take the inner product
between those coefficient vectors
and that's going to get me a new
polynomial yes right
somewhere in that space okay that's the
right way to think about this
um there was someone i think it might be
gilbert strang but
don't like i don't know who said
anything but someone once said
all of maths is a quest to reduce um any
problem to the axioms of linear algebra
and that's essentially what we've done
like how do we compose functions
we do it with a linear algebra and now
we can see i was slightly wrong
it doesn't give you a new polynomial it
will actually give you just the number
that's the inner product of these two
coefficient
vectors no you get a new function you
get a new function okay yeah because if
we reduce it to a vector form right
all the numbers in the vector change so
therefore we have a new polynomial
but of same degree but the inner product
wouldn't that inner product multiply
all the coefficients and then sum it
together
oh good no it's a good point it's also
called a scalar product
yes except uh they i think in this
particular case
uh because the the arguments to these
functions aren't of the same order it
doesn't collapse
but i could be completely foolish there
okay but
that was so i i can imagine what it
means to take the inner product of two
of these
functions and then where do we go from
there you said there was a special
function one or two there are two
special
there for each evaluation point there is
one
and only one unique function in the
space so we're
we're talking about one particular place
in my room
yeah the temperature of that particular
place there is
one function in the function space such
that
such that all of the potential functions
in the spun by the function space
we take the inner product of our special
function and any function
yeah and it will evaluate to that
function's value
at that point at the given point in your
room but so the inner product is now
the inner product between these two
functions is a number
because we've given it an argument and
we've evaluated it at that argument
the inner product we first take the
inner product between the two functions
and then we feed it the argument between
the two functions
yeah but what we're getting here is the
scalar product
this will like if we give it a numbered
argument it will reduce to the single
value
output and that this is a weird thing to
think about
but it like it basically this is one of
the parts where it's like follow the
math
it just jumps out of the math but in in
the name of trying to simplify this
if we were doing it with real value
functions to find
like temperature values in your room
then the evaluation functional would be
what
say 20 21 degrees because we're using
air conditioning
then that's going to get yes that's the
value that
say it's the perfect function we are
going to get that 21 degrees out
because the functions that evaluate to
that point
right the functions may be wrong
they may give us 100 degrees but with
this one other special function it will
reduce down to a scalar value
but this these these are abstract spaces
at the moment like where
in practice you don't use a hilbert
space you use it to construct other
spaces that
you do practical things with okay
yeah so like so you have for each point
you have a special function
and the inner product of that special
function with any other function
yes will turn out to be always this
number not it will be the value of the
number like
f of say we've got f of x right we want
to find f of x
so we get our evaluation functional at x
and we find our one
special function at x right and then
we pick the f right and the f no matter
which f we pick
we take inner product of those two
things in the high dimensional space
and it will give us our f of x
okay so that's a weird thing to have
happen you have a function within the
space that
behaves exactly like we exactly like the
one thing we want it to do
okay yeah and this again this is
abstract
we're never going to be calculating with
hilbert spaces in practice we're going
to turn it into matrices or
fourier bases somewhere and then do
something practical with it
a special function is different for each
point
that we evaluate at so if we get two of
them
and put them together we can use them to
create an equivalence between
evaluating a evaluating a function
at two points the inner product of two
points
are caught under a certain function in
the space and just
this special kernel function that we
build and that this is actually the
reproducing kernel
of the reproducing kernel hilbert space
because it basically what it does
is you you hit any function in the space
with this function
and you get the function back but
evaluate it and and that's why it's
called the reproducing kernel
okay all right oh yeah you when you do
it with two points it becomes a
reproducing kernel
right now these things have a couple of
neat properties one they're positive
semi-definite and they're going to be
symmetric
um and this is basically because we're
defining them in terms of an inner
product
and like on the theoretical side they
induce a unique every reproducing kernel
induces a unique reproducing kernel
hilbert space and vice versa
every reproducing kernel hilbert space
has a unique
reproducing kernel but here's where it
gets
cool every reproducing kernel is
semi-definite
is sorry positive definite and
occasionally positive semi-definite
but every positive definite kernel
function defines a unique
reproducing kernel hilbert space for
which it is the unique reproducing
kernel for
wow right so if we can just find a
function that has this nice property
we get this amazing optimization space
out of it like for free
yeah and that that's the core of what an
rkhs does
okay so yeah to track back if to go from
the other side if we
find any function where we plug in
two data points in our date nice data
space rd whatever
uh and it turns out to be positive
semi-definite
yeah just or positive definitive they're
called nurses conditions there's a bunch
of things you go to wikipedia
you do your proofs and you check that it
holds so
if this is the case any function
then we know that this corresponds to
these spaces yeah this so that we know
that for let's formulate this out we
know
that there is a
function space that has as
base like bases function and
what happens if we plug two data points
into
the kernel what happens is that
what we magically
the special function for x is gathered
and the special function for y
is gathered and then
now you have to complete my sentence
okay basically
what it does is it lets us evaluate the
inner product of
f of x and f of y which may be much
harder than calculating the original
function
okay that's again all we've done now is
we've shown this equivalence between
this
nifty little function that we can fairly
easily define
and a much trickier operation that may
be infinite dimensional or very high
dimensional or
don't want a computable but how does it
connect to these special functions that
we
before we said for each point there is
like this very special
function we take two of those special
functions
yeah for x and y and we take the inner
product of them
and that gives us the special function
that or the the other function that
allows us to do the inner product
without yeah so that's yeah that was it
from this side
yeah i think we made the connection to
what we had before
and i love this special function you
mean this fire thing this feature
yeah so that's this is one way of doing
it the fee it doesn't necessarily have
to be fear it can just be
a straight up in a product the the key
thing though
is we are pitching this as a
computational saving device
yes so you say you create this end by n
matrix so you just do this simple
transformation on the matrix itself and
you don't need to compute
all of these these intermediate feature
transformations on all of the pairs of
the examples
and supposedly it saves us loads and
loads of time but it doesn't
because as i said on the the radial
basis function
only the first few dimensions are
important on the polynomial you don't
really need that many anyway
and you're limited just on the
computational methods of how kernels are
used on
the number of examples that you could
use anyway so does it really save you
that much time in practice i mean in
practice
for small linear systems it's much
quicker especially if the the system's
like under
imposed right you've got way more
variables than you do
observations in in which case this gives
you something that your linear solver
isn't going to die
on and it gives you something that you
know especially for online applications
you can very quickly
have these things optimizing in real
time based on the last n
samples and use it for like noise
finding or anomaly detection or whatever
you want to do
but there's two things there's two
things though right because you said
that your linear solver wouldn't die on
but yeah you could still con so let's
say
original question you could still
construct that kernel by
computing the feature transformation on
all of the pairs without using the
kernel trick
and then you've still got the same thing
right well you just brought up the
kernel trick and
this is the beauty of it sometimes you
can't get that
feature map the map that gives you the
straight up vectors
or you don't like for whatever reason
you don't want to compute it in which
like the real use case here is the
radial basis function because
even if um even if you're only going out
to two terms
the the radial basis kernel itself is
it's just a pairwise
subtraction and then you put it into a
couple of floating point operations
things like exponents things like
divisions and it just pops out the other
side that's a fair
computational saving i'd argue the
motivation here
like with deep learning what it is the
real motivation here is
like these things have nice theoretical
properties they're really nice to
understand
other problems they're not always
practical they have niche applications
if we're making an argument based on
like pure computational efficiency for
big problems
no as soon as your data gets big they're
no good this is why
you shouldn't really ever bother with
them unless you've got very good
computational budget reason reasons to
consider them
that that they're fairly robust but but
again devil's advocate i recommend
people check this lecture out by the way
by caltech
they've got a pretty good lecture on
kernel methods and it actually shows the
expansion for this
polynomial sorry this gaussian the
radial basis function kernel
and you can see here that it's a taylor
series expansion and the sum here is is
to infinity
but and it it decays very quickly right
so the basis function it goes up at the
beginning and then it it um decays very
quickly and it kind of converges towards
zero and you're summing up
over this sum but i guess my point is we
make a big song and dance about
oh having infinite dimensions is a good
thing
but it's not really game changing is it
we could easily just use the polynomial
kernel compute it directly don't use the
kernel trick at all
we wouldn't be much worse off would we
the infinite dimensional things are red
herring it
people get tripped up on it people think
the infinite dimensions is
no that just gives us a nice search
space yes we're doing infinite
dimensional stuff
but it's a complete distraction people
think that's the secret of success and
it's not
if any the whole point of the
representative theorem which
uh we'll get to in a bit uh how we for
time we got another half hour
i've got some constraints okay cool
we've got plenty of time but
when we get to the representative
theorem the whole point is we do away
with all of the extra dimensions we
don't want them they're
they're a distraction and and they are
actively unhelpful
but yeah the having all these extra
dimensions
may may simplify things for us
often they do because we don't need like
a lot of the variation across the data
set
gets removed and and like a soft nearest
neighbors like
thinking of kernel methods as a soft
nearest neighbors is a fairly good
a fairly good way to approach it all
we're doing is we're saying how similar
are these data points to others
other data points if it's more efficient
to do the full inner product than do the
full inner product
let's talk about that because this
radial basis function that's one of
these um i think it was it called a
homogeneous kernel where it's it's only
a function of the the distance between
examples right so you likened it to
being a bit like nearest neighbor
and there are even i forget the name of
this approach is it kernel
density methods where you just drop
gaussian kernels on top of all of the
examples and you create this landscape
it's not too dissimilar to that right so
you're building this landscape it's
different in terms of
the whole point of the structure that's
more done for integration or
like integrability but yeah it's not
ridiculously different we are dropping
some
gaussian distance function and then
using that to build up a map
of density of points and when you're
doing
a radial basis regression you are
literally just saying how far is this
point from
every other point oh this points a one
and this point's a zero oh my new point
is
more similar to the one than the zero it
must be a one
right it's not it's not rocket science
but i guess i'm just trying to
understand what are all of the key
advantages here
and clearly the first advantage is being
able to use
linear i think you said strang says that
everything goes towards linear algebra
so
we're using linear methods to
potentially
regress or classify in non-linear spaces
and that doesn't require the kernel
trick it just requires some
non-linear transformation into a space
there might be some computational
characteristics which make this quite
nice
where's the real gain here again i'd say
the real gain unless you've got a good
reason for implementing the kernel
method
then go for a deep neural network if
your goal is performance
go for a deep neural network the the
real gain here of reducing it to this
linear operation
in like a hilbert space is you can
attack
you know say you want to figure out how
to make your attention kernel more
efficient you can you've now got a set
of theoretical tools
which either very well founded and
fairly robust
that you can use to attack this problem
say you've got a distance measure that
doesn't quite work
right it doesn't quite hold these
methods are so robust that you can stick
like kale divergence for example
you can still use these methods on kl
divergence kernel i have no idea what
the expansion of that would be it'd
probably be simpler to calculate it some
other way
but you can do it right you come up with
a distance metric and then you run
regression on it and it'll work
and then you can use these tools to
explore
why it works and to explore the kinds of
relationships the kinds of functions
that it's giving you
you know that i'd argue that's the big
advantage it's not that
these models were good for their time
they're basically obsolete now they have
very niche applications in things like
meta learning approaches or you're
putting on top of semi-supervised
models like old everything old is new
again
but in general like it's not about the
performance it's about the fact that
these things are provable like they're
not like a
neural network where there comes a point
where we just start waving our hands and
then say universal function
approximation theorem
in this case we can say exactly what's
going on we can write down exactly
what's going on
and so forth statistician or something
just quickly on that point because i was
watching that caltech lecture and the
guy was saying there's some really
interesting theoretical properties about
maximum margin uh classifiers in general
and first of all you would expect if you
use this radial basis function that
almost every single example would be a
support vector so it'd be propping up
the hyperplane but typically that
doesn't happen actually at some
percentage
it might be 10 of the examples or so on
and you can um theoretically
there's a theorem which is a function of
the number of support vectors which
gives you uh
an estimate of your out of samples all
sorts of interesting things like that
you were saying earlier about like how
do we not end up in cursed
dimensionality city
i i actually forgot to reread that paper
i read that paper
a couple of months ago and i thought
i'll have to reread it and then
completely forgot
but yeah par part of the because so few
of these points actually
contribute to the outputs in maximum
margin
classifiers you do get this improved
imperviousness
to to dimensionality like it doesn't go
away it's just not as big of a problem
and you know how big of a problem it
will be because you can put bounds on it
i believe that was the output anyway but
we shouldn't be looking at the
these things as the new state of the art
they're never going to beat that
because one we've made a huge assumption
over the kinds of relationships that
we're likely to find in our data
we've defined that by our kernel
function but what they are useful for is
if we find ourselves say we're doing
style transfer say we're doing an
attention mechanism
and we note that hey this thing that i'm
generating here it's
all inner products or it's all positive
semi-definite and
code's a similarity metric all of a
sudden you can attack that you can start
to say hang on
okay what's going on here i want to make
i don't want to do an
n-cubed operation here i want to get it
down to n log n
all right let's go look at the sparse
kernel literature and see what lives in
there
you know that's the real advantage here
not that it's going to give you
amazing performance but allows you to
understand what you're doing so that
your
search for improvements isn't a blind
search through just engineering trial
and error
you can say okay what do we actually
know about the problem and start to
exploit those properties
to make advancements well to bring it
back
tim could you show that lecture slide
again um because i i think
that illustrates it very nicely with
what's going on with inner products
and infinite dimensions and so on so if
we just look at this
so this the exponential or the is it the
exponential kernel
the radio bases radial basis kernel
sorry
so on the bottom we would see what you'd
have to do
if you were to compute this explicitly
right
so you'd have to compute for data point
one you'd have to complete compute all
the blue things
like including every single thing in the
sum
and then keep them around you can't do
the sum without the orange thing
so you need to compute all the blue
thing and all the orange things
and then you need to then you basically
have two vectors and then you need to
compute
the inner product which is in this case
is an is an infinite sum
uh but you could just plug that in on
top
and that would we know for a fact i
would give you
the exact same thing as if you were to
if you were to do that and all of these
functions somehow
have these properties so even absent of
what not infinite dimensions and so on
we've seen this pop up in transformers
right in these kind of linear
transformers already
where we know we have to do this giant
inner product matrix in these attention
mechanisms
and these people said instead of this
we might just want to use like a kernel
method to reduce that
uh down yes is that okay so it has
various applications right
so we can think of this and throw this
into some higher dimension
or but also it actually has practical
engineering
applications what do you how does that
hit you this kind of how people use it
in transformers how do you what do you
make of that
i i think that this is the right way to
start thinking about these things
right we don't need to reinvent
everything a lot of this work has been
done
there's a lot of good research in making
these things more computationally
efficient
again don't use them as the basis of
models notice that you're doing kernely
stuff
in your model and go maybe we can
improve this maybe we can find an
alternate formulation
where we where we go to okay we we now
have
some of these notions of kernels and
inner products and so on
so what do we do with them because
usually the
let's say academic literature lectures
what not
at some point they come up and say
here's this margin thing so how does
this connect because
if you build up support vector machines
generally
margin appears as simply the distance
between
class a and class b and you can have
soft margin and hard margin and then all
of a sudden kernels appear
all right so that kind of i believe that
actually
comes out of a slightly different branch
but it was around at the same time as
all the kernel theory was really getting
developed
i think that one popped out of the no
free lunch theorem
the there are multiple planes that can
split the data
but we want to find the one the best one
um the reason that it pairs with kernels
is because you can modify
a linear solver in in a neat way
you you use a regularized a regularized
empirical risk problem on this positive
semi-definite matrix
and you will you can modify it to have
this maximum margin
property with it and that just
it happens that these two things worked
well together probably because
the space is very high dimensional and
so not just finding an arbitrary line
but finding a big line
a line with the maximum distance
separating the classes
tends to mitigate that somewhat that's
svm
but really for the purpose of
understanding kernels and how they work
it's probably better just
get to kernel regression get like once
you've got kernel regression under your
head go okay now we start pairing it
with crazy optimizers and this new loss
function
and some nice hyper parameter tuning oh
we're gonna throw in some sparse
operations to compute everything super
rapidly
and that's that's where the svm
literature took off it had its own
engineering phase that engineered these
really efficient routines for
calculating them and that was a big part
of the reason for their success i think
they get lumped in in the lectures
because you are
building towards svms you're not
building towards kernel regression
because
people hear kernel regression they go
well it's just linear regression yeah
but
the kernel eyes if you're going to build
towards a kernel method you're going to
build towards
svms because you're not going to build
towards bayesian non-parametrics it's
too complicated and there's too many
other things that need to be bought in
but yeah i i don't know i i think
the the hinge loss the way they lead
into it and say oh it pairs with kernels
well it also pairs with neural networks
right it's just a loss function at the
end of the day it's just a loss function
i certainly think there's something
magic about ridge regression in
particular just because it's beautifully
simple
it's least squares with this
regularization term
you're looking for this parameter vector
w which is basically
the line and then there's a
regularization term where you want w to
be
quite small and then you can solve it in
dual
uh form and you can realize and
what's beautiful about kernel wood
regression is there's a closed form
solution so you have to
compute a matrix inverse of the kernel
you know the covariance matrix
and then weirdly you have to multiply it
by the target labels
but it's just a beautiful thing and and
it's quite complicated to solve an
inverse of a matrix but because i think
it's cubic time complexity but you can
rearrange it to solve a linear
system and you can even do some kind of
if you're doing online ridge regression
you can do like a sliding
incremental update version so you can
basically do it in linear time
and yeah there's something magic about
that yeah and that's really
the the point where you see ridge
regression and then the jewel of it
and you're just like oh that's a matrix
of inner products what happens if i
change out my distance or similarity
metric
and you just drop in whatever metric you
want and it works
that's a special moment that's like
whole it feels like you're tapping into
something deep there
that's really where all the um where all
the the hilbert space kind of stuff
comes in
because it enables that transformation
it enables you to see that you're taking
a bunch of inner products
oh maybe we want some other distance i
don't know if anyone's ever tried it
with
um with style transfer i know they're
starting to try it with attention
but surely there's more ground to be
gained there the
people suddenly being aware that oh
we're doing a whole heap of inner
products maybe we can do something
internally here
maybe something interesting will come of
that maybe it won't research works in
weird ways but
i genuinely think the more people
understand the
the matrixes the matrices that they're
looking at aren't just aren't just
arrays of numbers they have special
properties that you can exploit that you
can find
cool things to do with yeah the more
people look at it that way i think the
more the field will progress
overall so to to to get there
is it's because we've skipped over a
number of things quite like
like so all of a sudden we're talking
about ridge regression which
as tim said is least squares with a with
a regularizer
and then the dual of that is so i don't
know if everyone knows
what a duel is it always seemed like a
magical word to me
but some problems have a dual
formulation where it's simply
a different way of writing down a
problem and for a special
class of these problems this dual
version
if you solve it it gives you the exact
same solution
as what as the original one which is
called primal then for a wider class it
gives you a bound on the solution it
doesn't actually give you the same
solution but you
think there's a little gap remaining but
i've
in this case i guess it gives you the
same solution so it's just a different
way of writing the problem but in this
different way
of writing the problem all of a sudden
it's not
least squares but it's somehow inner
products appear
yeah right so in this range of
regression do you guys want to walk
through
ridge regression real briefly yeah we
can do that and
what's interesting about the ridge
regression is that there is a closed
form solution for the primal as well i
think and
that is you have to invert an m by m
matrix and that which is the number of
attributes
squared and because there's a
computational tradeoff because if you
use the dual formulations
on the n by n then it means that you
have to invert
potentially a very large matrix if you
have a lot of examples
yeah and then that's really the killer
thing with these kernel or kernel
methods generally
you do end up with these big sort of
outer products of data matrices and if
you've got a million observations then
good luck calling that into memory i'm
going to sit back and wait while you
scream at your computer to respond again
yeah because it does just make me think
that this is great because people say oh
deep learning is ridiculous
and it's computationally intractable but
in many ways there's some beautiful
properties about deep learning i love
the way
learning and the backdrop algorithm and
you can send mini batches through it and
so on and
these svms that they work on incredibly
parsimonious problems where you have
hardly any examples but computationally
they seem to blow up
quicker than deep learning yeah i'm
always amused when people
start talking about oh neural tangent
kernels they're fantastic
we can simulate a neural network by
getting its similarity function and just
directly calculating it
and then even on a problem like mnist
they're calling into existence
a 60 000 by 60 000 matrix and
you know on every evaluation they have
to evaluate 60 000 times
to fit that into the problem yeah that's
a nice
because part of me just thinks that svms
are from they were from a time
when we had hardly any because we used
to work on like the boston housing data
centers had 506 examples on and
the main heuristic with svms was this
notion that the maximum margin works
really well but for deep learning we
have so many examples
we're solving a completely different
type of problem the magical thing about
deep learning for me is that it's more
akin to software
it's like a sequence of steps and
you can learn the entire sequence end to
end as part of the training pro
process so you can do something really
sophisticated in many steps
and it just seems like such an exciting
paradigm compared to what we're talking
about here which is
learning the optimal separating hyper
plane in a bunch of data points then you
come across like gaussian processors
where it's an
it's literally an infinite parameter
model you know
it it's a model that grows in complexity
as your data set grows
and that's an exciting idea all by
itself like bayesian nonparametrics in
general
is a fascinating field because it's
these models that
grow in in complexity with response to
like how complex the data is
and these methods are fundamentally
kernel methods they look a lot like the
the dual formulation of ridge regression
so again the the promise here isn't that
that they're going to do things more
effectively
like a deep neural network will beat it
on performance any day of the week
unless it's like some trivial toy
problem in which case maybe
instability of your parameters comes to
to bite you
but i think they are fascinating because
there's this
i think svm's worked really well when
you've hardly got any data
yep yep but are you saying that when you
have lots of data or when
also the the beauty of deep learning is
that they have inductive priors that
allow
them to work quite well on unstructured
data without having to create features
and so on presumably
that that's a huge advantage as well
that's an advantage if you've got lots
of data that accurately represents your
problem but if you don't necessarily
have that or you want an explicit
relationship to be modeled then these
are actually liabilities
and there are cases where you can't do
this i'm always talking about andrew
gellman because i think the man's
brilliant but he's got this fantastic
graph on the
the front cover of bda3 bayesian data
analysis 3
that breaks down a number of births
across time across years
spikes in the days etc and this was all
done with multi-level
nested gaussian processors it's a
fascinating
bit of statistics but you couldn't just
say oh well give me a black box on the
relationship here because you'd be
picking up all kinds of noise and you
wouldn't know how to interpret it
so where interpretability is important
manually specifying these things is
often
useful yeah the to go back
a bit to how we even get there in the
discussion
with deep learning and all if i can
continue
where i was before saying that okay
there is a way to look at ridge
regression where these inner products
appear
now this and then you said okay we're
doing kernely things and and this is
exactly where we get
with the transformers where people say
look in this transformer thing we don't
even need to go to dual
there's just this thing right here
there's this inner product of all the
the data points or the elements in the
set and transformers
and for some reason like this this inner
product matrix is there what is
what happens if we just replace this
by this kernel because we know kernels
are inner products
now in ridge regression if we change
the inner product to be a kernel we know
that it corresponds to an inner product
in some other space
and now we're doing basically we're
doing regression
on points that live in that other space
implicitly right yes so we're doing
we're doing regression in that
y so my question here is this
it seems given the number of kernels
that exist
this is not necessarily a better thing
first of all
this is actually the space where we're
at might be pretty good for regression
or it might not be pretty good for
regression is
the fact that these kernel methods work
so well just that
we have found kernels namely let's say
the rbf kernel
we've found this kernel that just
appears to really
express pretty well natural data
is that an intuition or is there
something more special about that kernel
because
for any kernel function it can make it
worse or it can make it better
i think you've hit the nail on the head
there that on many layers
one it could be that our inner products
are the best possible distance metric
particularly when you consider the
dynamics of back propagation
and like what throwing exponents in
there for very small numbers will do to
stability etc
it could be that the rbf corresponds to
the distribute the natural distribution
of data
pretty well and i think that's the
current going hypothesis
and it certainly feels that way i barely
maybe test
other kernel functions before i decide
that the rbf's going to work for me
it's really a case of we don't know
whether or not other functions may work
better and
even if other functions don't work
better the fact that it
has this kernel representation means
that we can
think about solving these in frequency
space
for example or your principled methods
of
uh reducing the overall number of points
that we look at so
like a sub sampling method or other
spectral methods involving
svds or something like that would these
be computationally if it more efficient
i don't know would they give better
performance yeah but we're not going to
know unless we check
and as opposed to just randomly trying
things being like hey this has worked
for this entire literature for 20 years
is a fairly good guide that maybe we
should try it
on the problems that we're facing now
cool yeah all right sorry yeah i mean
just one more quick contrast deep
learning right it's
it's mini batch based and you're
fundamentally learning
a continuous geometric morphing from one
manifold to another
and it's beautiful because you can just
put in one mini batch at a time and you
can just do stochastic gradient descent
god knows why it works
watch the annex video on ensemble
methods and it's really interesting how
in these high dimensional spaces
it's actually surprisingly convex but
there are many basins of attraction and
initial starting weights you go into a
different one although it still works
you in quite an equivalent way but this
is completely different
this conceptually this is more like
nearest neighbor you're
rather than cursoring through the data
set you're you're taking all of the
examples you're looking at all of the
pairwise distances and then you're
doing stuff in that space that seems a
little bit old hat to me
it it certainly look it does but there
are applications where you can't just
mini-batch your way through it and
things like point clouds even
representing a point cloud in a sensible
manner
doesn't necessarily doesn't necessarily
translate to neural network performance
generally you have to find some
coordinate system
or some coordinate free system with
which you can represent these things
one way which you can do this is
pairwise distances and uh
there's a great book out there it's in
pre-print at the moment but you can
download the whole thing by free
for free called geometric data analysis
it's by the guy who made uh the
i don't know how to pronounce it co-ops
package ke ops
for pytorch as well as a pie torch
implementation of
regularized washer stein distances etc
and it's it's a fantastic
it walks through exactly the sorts of
problems you encounter
once you move beyond these nice com
specifically cnn friendly data
structures
and things like distances work fine
there because you don't require a
coordinate system
to be able to represent things
accurately so there are applications
where this works but yeah the fact that
it gives you a com
a convex problem that is that will have
a global optima
even though in the data space it's
hideously non-linear
these ideas i used to just ignore them
and laugh
a friend of mine liam hodgkinson he's uh
where is he at the moment stanford i
think he
he was just imploring me one evening but
don't you care if there's a solution i'm
like no as long as my training my
validation accuracy is good i don't care
but the more i think the more i think
it's right it's nice to know that it'll
go
somewhere because if it's the middle
layer of some
multi-gpu monstrosity the last thing you
want is it diverging
two million dollars into training with
another million dollars of wasted time
to burn
yeah to wrap up a bit how do we get from
all of this to the representer theorem
and what is that
okay so the representative theorem we've
come jumping back and forth
i had a cool thing where we we went from
basics i should have known that i was
dealing with engineers but
you know the the representative theorem
key to how we tie together
these weird funky functions and
and a problem that we can actually solve
the representative theorem i'm gonna
basically read from my notes here
because it's a bit complicated so
first in wikipedia speak is every
function
in the rkhs that minimizes a regularized
empirical risk functional can be
represented as a finite linear
combination of kernel products
evaluated on the input points in the
training data set
so to pass that into simpler forms
our optimum function our best function
can be
represented but the one that minimizes
our loss
can be represented as some kind of a
linear problem
on the dart on the kernel functions of
the data set
so we just what this is saying is we
take the kernel products of our data
and we run linear regression on now how
do we get there
the first thing is we know that we've
got our feature maps which we'll call
fee
and our our magic reproducing kernels
which we'll call k
and we're looking for some magic
function f star which is our
the function that minimizes our
empirical risk because this is a hilbert
space it's a vector space we can
break this into two chunks the chunk
that is
that has the bases given by our fees
which and we just take a weighted sum of
them
and its complement and that's an
infinite dimensional space we can't do
anything with it
but we can show that the result is in an
infinite dimensional space because we
use an infinite dimensional kernel
uh is it an infinite dimensional space
because of
something else it's it could be infinite
dimensional because our basis functions
are infinite dimensional themselves but
even then the space
is still we're using those bases as the
those functions as the bases for our
space literally every other potential
function
imaginable lives in that space okay so
it's big
it's really big and but what we can show
is
that the result i'm not going to talk
through the proof i don't even remember
the proof there's a good proof
wikipedia is a great uh reference for
maths it's the only subject that
wikipedia is any good for
but you can show that the optimum
function
must live in the basic and the basis of
of those fees the fees of our training
data points
because it's an empirical risk
functional and the
the contribution of the complement of
the space all those other
infinite functions must be equal to zero
right so we can safely ignore all of the
space except for that
is given by our data points right so
that this space
is made up of i take every
possible data point that i can imagine
nope and
only the ones that you have only the
ones that i
yeah wait but which ones are then zero
every other data point that's what i'm
saying that's what i'm saying
i take the space of every possible data
point that i could imagine
and run them through my fee function
right through my
function in this whatever this either if
it's a polynomial kernel i run it
through the polynomial
or i just map it to this high
dimensional space and that gives me like
a giant space
and every possible data point
gives rise to one basis direction in
that space
and then the solution to my
problem that i have which is in a
completely different like has nothing to
do with this space like this space
per se knows nothing about what i'm
trying to minimize over here
because it doesn't even have the labels
right yeah but yet still i know that the
solution
to whatever problems i could throw at
this
data set must live in some kind of a
linear combination of these five vectors
okay yeah so that basically says that i
all i have to do is ask all the data
points what they think
yeah about a given solution and they
will
i don't need to do anything else
basically yeah
even though you and and this is kind of
the problem with these
hilbert spaces that they are infinite
then you need to consider
the whole infinity of them but because
we're doing empirical risk minimization
which
our function space doesn't know about
our labels but our empirical risk
operator our empirical risk functional
will
the point that minimizes that is our
optimum point
and that will lie in the basis of the
vectors given or the not the vectors the
bases given by
our feature map our map into the feature
space
which could be highly non-linear or
non-computable
and okay so here's the question why is
this
let's say surprising because i can say
it's obviously it's like a giant space
already like it's
every data point is a base direction
pretty much any function is probably in
there somewhere
well because the the problem's
non-linear in our data space but it's
linear in our feature space
because it's linear in our feature space
it's linear in our kernel space
and our kernel function we can compute
very efficiently because the
evaluation functional is linear and
continuous
that's more just a guarantee that you
can search through the space it's
because
the feature map we can show that a
feature map
if it obeys certain properties is
positive definite and it's
it'll give us our own reproducing kernel
for that particular data point
so those kernel functions themselves are
what we run
regression on we we don't worry about
the feature maps right think back to the
exponential kernel we're not doing that
in
infinite sum where we're just going to
do it on the the pairwise distance run
through some exponent
and that will give us our answer
right like in in terms of so now now
what i'm understanding is okay
instead of doing super duper non-linear
regression
what i i can do is i can
do linear regression in this big space
or
i can do linear regression in the kernel
space yeah and but what that means is
my data points are like the inputs to my
kernel function
but i need to do linear regression in
the kernel space and the kernel itself
is not a linear function so
a little bit it's like back prop right
where i have the loss at the end what
comes out of the kernel i put into
my loss my risk minimization and then i
need to know
somehow the gradient with respect to the
convex combination coefficients well
kind of what we're doing in that space
remember is inner products we're going
to draw these hyper planes in the the
feature space
which we can express as these kernel as
these pairwise
sort of kernel functions it's linear in
that
kernel space because we're just taking a
weighted sum of the kernels
which is equivalent to searching through
a weighted sum
of the feature space which we don't want
to calculate
and so what it ends up looking like is
when you normally do linear regression
you get coefficients
on the variables and instead what we're
going to do is we're going to get
coefficients on the data points
we're saying which data point if you're
similar to which data point what does
that mean for the
for the probability of a target label
and framed in those terms it's a fairly
straightforward
jump to see how you can how it can be
non-linear
but linearly solvable and it kind of
links the nearest neighbor etcetera but
you usually yeah there is this
formulation especially in the svm
there's a formulation with this convex
quadratic optimizers but this
technically is solvable by gradient
descent
do it with atom for fun in python it
works
right like that and yeah all the stuff
about
quadratic optimizers that's that's some
other kettle of fish most people
they don't even look at that stuff you
can solve this
in pi torch having a bit of fun with
loss functions and auto
i could think about but i do it in step
wise fashion
but every single step i need to pass all
my data
through the kernel all my combinations
every two data points i need to pass
through the kernel
in every iteration step and then i need
to calculate the gradients with respect
to how much i weigh each day in in
practice you wouldn't even do that you
just
calculate the kernel matrix and then do
regression on that and
take the kernel matrix as your data and
that's and now you're starting to see
why these methods have fallen out of
fashion
because storing that matrix is a pain
and you need to store all the data
points to do inference
so for a particular solution let's say i
do that
and i obtain my obtain my solution which
is
is given as a combination of data points
basically so whenever i want to classify
a new data point what that means is
i have to calculate the kernel
with each other data point in my data
set then do this
weighting that i got so basically every
data point
gives its opinion about this new point
yes weights that i have predetermined
and okay and then there is a somehow a
property that arises that it's not
actually every data point but only very
few
on the maximum under maximum margin yes
okay
so that's not foreign function no if
you're just doing say linear regression
or like
kernel regression or a continuous output
right
the it is robust because it's like
voting
but you do get that kind of the
robustness from having
more points and a single outlier against
we've lost you alex
the chinese firewall has struck again
which is good because as soon as the
call actually dropped i swore my head
off
yeah it's it it gets some robustness
from the fact it's comparing to multiple
points so it
has to be a systematic set of outliers
that causes overfitting rather than just
a very large value with respect to a
single point
but okay so we have the in maximum
margin
the contribution of most data points is
close to zero or exactly zero
um close to zero it's close to zero
except if you
i guess you could put the usual l1
regularizer and
but maybe i don't know but if okay
but actually in gaussian processes or
things of that nature you really have
all the data points sort of
voting on a new data point and so on and
that means the more data points you have
the more complex your model becomes yes
yes it's worse because it goes from like
a
a quadratic calculation to a cubic
calculation
okay now can you can you connect this
to what we currently see in like nlp
where we know that these big giant
models
okay it's they're they're not
non-parametric they are very much
parametric but we still know that what
we have to do is
we have to scale up the data
and the model size comparably if we
scale up the data and the model size
comparably
then we get large gains these models
become much more powerful
and that is the same thing as adding
more data points to these
yeah these kind of kernel methods like
do you see a connection there or
absolutely in the as our data gets more
complex our model gets more complex
we had a bit of a chat last night about
doing fully bayesian neural networks and
how this may or how you can do things
like automatically determining
the appropriate size of your model as
well as what type of parameters you can
have
at least in a distributional sense and
thinking about like how this relates to
gaussian processors
basic nonparametrics these giant text
models
first of all can i say i will never
advocate ever
doing bayesian non-parametrics on that
sort of scale like
there's only so many tears my computer
can cry before it doesn't care anymore
but the idea of making a bigger model
for more complex data
is that's a very natural concept the
only real trick with these kernel
methods
particularly as they apply to gaussian
processors is that it's all
determined by the data though the
parameters are implicit parameters
they're not if if a lot of your data
points are very similar or the same
then the actual complexity of the model
doesn't grow that much
even though the size will and really
it's memory that kills kernel methods
nine times out of ten okay which is
ironic because
it's used to save memory in transformers
yeah yeah and it it works there for that
very
specific reason that the trend the
attention kernel is a fixed size so we
can pre-allocate it and do all of the
nice efficient cuda ops
if you're your attention kernels were to
grow in size
then there's also a reason that
transformers are very heavily limited
into
in terms of how big they can get because
those that memory footprint gets
very large very quickly so apart from
let's say transformers do you have any
suspicion of where we're going to
seek kernel methods kernelization any
sort of that appear back into modern
deep learning
style transfer and super resolution
okay style transfer for fair or
hopefully fairly obvious reasons you're
doing a lot of ground matrix stuff in
there
to actually start to calculate loss
functions and there may be isolations or
at least
maybe not colonizations but alternate
distance metrics
that give better performance in that
space that would be
one outreach and in super resolution
there's actually some cool stuff going
on here at the moment guys doing some
fairly insane
on device super resolution and
if you look closely you can see a lot of
small artifacts so the deep learning
process is
really good for getting approximate
solutions but it's really bad for
getting close solutions
in fact i was trying to do camera pose
estimation and simultaneous location and
mapping and found that
you could get a very good approximate
answer but if you wanted an exact answer
even if the
perturbation was really small the
answers were just garbage
um so in that sort of sense being able
to solve
that last mile step if you've got things
very close
and you just want to make them perfect
having a series of very small
convex optimization problems that can be
ran very quickly
provides a grounding for taking the next
step forward and if that sounds a bit
a bit abstract it's what's powering
uh the google pixel phone the super
resolution they do without deep learning
just from using the shaking of your hand
as you take a photo
they then use kernel methods to optimize
what each pixel should be in a super
resolution sense and they can do it like
in a
split second because these problems are
very small and can be solved
so quickly but is it the computational
performance
thing or because you said it's also an
exact solution so
it's better on the style transfer for
example you said it was about
a loss function yeah for deep learning
to work well it needs to be
end to end and the loss function needs
to be differentiable and so on so how
does that work
why would they choose to use a kernel
for that because they're already using
gram matrices
as a way of measuring similarity between
outputs i
think they throw like a vgg model added
or something like that
um conventionally and then look at layer
14 15
and see how similar the outputs there
are and then you basically you do
gradient descent back to your original
image
and edit the image so that upper that
upper feature layer is very similar
or has very similar outputs to
it's done two ways anyway one's on the
norm of the ground matrix ones on the
ground matrix itself
so a different distance function like i
don't know washerstein distance
kl divergence or something like that
would yield uh
a different notion of what similarity
looks like
because if you think back to the early
days doing vae
image generation people using least
squares for that and just getting this
horrible blurry mess
and that's because you know least
squares is a horrible blurry loss
function
taking an inner product is similar it's
it has a lot of the same sort of
problems with it in terms of using it as
a distance metric it's
liable to be affected by outliers it
ignores small differences rather than
having a nice sharp
point at the bottom of it like an l1
loss function would so
exploring different different distance
metrics at least
would give a different kernel matrix
that would represent
the notion of similarity in a a way that
may be more
amenable to like deep learning based
optimization
it it may be that the the whole system
sufficiently non-linear that doing
anything other than a gram matrix
is wasting computation and messing with
your gradients that may be the case 100
but it may also be that a better choice
of distance function in that space
does give better results and i think
that's worth investigating
would there be a more fundamental we
could both comment on this but as i said
kernel methods are fundamentally related
to nearest neighbor
and deep learning methods are
fundamentally related to
perturbing or mutating examples
from one place to another place so could
we just modify deep learning to be a
little bit more like
this nearest neighbor approach really is
that a naive thing to say we
if you think about a deep learning model
as a kind of distance function you
absolutely can in fact you can calculate
exactly the kernel that a deep learning
model
would generate like you can do
kernelized deep learning
in practice it doesn't work very well
because the memory constraints
but like we're not talking about
completely separate things here we're
just looking at
the same problem in different ways one
of the one of the big advantages with
deep learning of course is that we can
do this mini batching
we can put in we can sub sample our data
and put in little chunks at a time as
opposed to having to hold it all in
memory
but just on on that sorry to label the
point a little bit and i'm sure you you
can
put some flavor on this but last week we
spoke to facebook research today talking
about this
new unsupervised clustering
representation learning algorithm
and it wasn't directly looking at the
distance between things it was doing it
indirectly and i think that's what deep
learning does earns features and
actually indirectly it's learning to
group similar things together especially
semantically similar things but you're
not directly looking at the distance
between examples and you're cursoring
through the data set
yeah thinking it really comes back to
primal dual linear regression one is
looking at the covariance between your
predictors the others looking at the
covariance between your observations
and it's just which side of the matrix
do you regress on
how i i guess that's how i view
this divide between the deep learning
and kernel methods it's not that it's so
much a divide it's just
one's a more efficient way of doing one
thing and the other's more efficient way
of doing the other
final thoughts my question to you alex
is
we've been talking a lot about what i
would say are statistical
approaches for doing clever pattern
recognition and so on
yeah and it seems a little bit divorced
from intelligence right
yeah yeah i i think i i think
talking about intelligence like a lot of
ai a lot of artificial intelligence is
just marketing speak
fundamentally what we're doing at the
moment is statistics we're doing very
clever statistics but it's not
intelligence
but labeling intelligence itself is a
very difficult problem
and we've discussed in the past talking
about putting a number on intelligence
but i think that's even the wrong
approach i think the better approach is
to treat intelligence
like the definition of pornography that
is i'll know it when i see it
i missed the light speed culture i'm no
longer a light speed
that's the i know you are
warp speed 10 if you've demonstrated it
then
it's not something you lose i see i see
yeah i have nothing
to say except i i really enjoyed this i
think this is tremendous
the the
i don't know i've learned like because i
think for all of us that happens and for
many people
listen as i said at the beginning we've
heard all of these things at some point
and then at some point you have a
homework and it's like here a show
representer
and you do something okay you look at
the wikipedia and the solutions and
you're trying to get the points but yeah
i i find this very exciting especially
that this final connection that
kind of the the data points are the
model
and our recognition now that we've gone
away from this we've gone
to neural networks which we fed through
data and we're like ha we have this
parametric thing right here we don't we
can throw away the data points to
to to the transformers where we know
we can't just increase the parameters we
also need to increase
the data which to me is the same thing
even though it ends up
being you can maybe evaluate quicker
because you can just forward past but
it's
i just i feel like there is a kind of a
reconnection in
in that space happening definitely and
and i'm excited to see what happens in
the future so yeah alex
this was great thank you very much that
was an absolute pleasure
doing this same same from from me alex
i've learned so much today it's been an
absolute pleasure having you on
the thing is though i'm going to let you
into a little secret alex
we've already done two other shows that
we haven't put them out there yet so we
had a session with keith last night and
we had a preamble session a few weeks
ago and
i think alex is a great guy and he's
gonna he's gonna be coming on the show a
little bit more often so it's been a
real pleasure to have you on alex
i i enjoy just being able to ask any
dumb
quest because i often feel like
people may be listening to something
like this they'll have
some dumb question and then i feel like
i have the same like idiot like the same
question
wait a minute is this like this other
thing and then
it was very relaxing to just be able to
to ask that whereas in a lecture
or even in the video lecture or even in
a real lecture if there's 400 people
there you wouldn't be like i'm sorry
what again is the square symbol
this is literally how i learned maths
just being like
my background's in the military i've
learned a foreign language i learned
that
very quickly that you've just got to not
be afraid to look like an idiot
sometimes
and so at university i'd always be the
guy being like hang on
you know what's this and they'd be like
oh that's an eigenvalue and i'd be like
ah i can value you know look that up
later
and that's the only it's the only way i
got good
nice yeah all right cool you think yeah
yeah okay thanks so much guys
take care guys see you later peace out